Delighted to be here this evening and what I'd like to do is tell you almost a little history lesson
because it goes way back in my career in terms of where we got started with eyes
And then progresses through another sense noses and then as
my research evolved we got into
Measuring biology instead of instead of mimicking it. So here's the outline first, we're going to talk about
mimicking biology and we're going to talk about measuring biology and
with respect to mimicking I've collected a lot of
things with biology that really are features of biological systems
that if you're trying to mimic it these are some of the features that you'd like to mimic and
You know you can kind of read this and go through it but you know there's there's a lot of things in here or some
of these are big words but you know information-rich
Self-organizing noisy you know these are things that we tend to not think about when we design
Technologies
Because we want to take noise out of the system but the brain uses noise all the time
As sort of a set point the heart has intrinsic noise built into it
what I'd like to do is is focus really on two senses this evening eyes first and
this is the
Compound eye of a very small fly you can see what are called the pixelation and the compound eye of an insect
operates very differently from the eyes that we have we have
Refractive optics we have a lens these are more like CCD cameras more like CMOS cameras the the things that exist in your mobile phone
Because what they do is each of these little
Simple eyes in this compound eye picks up just a little
Part of the full image and then the brain reconstructs that in the insect so it's not as if it's seeing
Something as we? See it sees
Pixelated images and the technological analogs of this this is a scanning electron
Have a very high magnification image of the camera that's in your iPhone and each of these is a little
detector that picks up just part of the image but there's so many of these that when it projects back to us the
resolution in our eyes is not good enough to see the pixelation and the image that has actually been captured this is a
Magnified version of the LCD screen and a Samsung you know 4k high resolution
Television set and there's
blue green and red
pixels and
One or two or three of these are on at a time to project a red green blue or
purple or yellow or white image on the screen but
when you look at that screen as
large as it is you can't really see
those
Individual pixels in that screen because your eye, does not have the resolution to resolve that but
When you magnify it you can you can see it and so that's that's
Similar to the compound eye of a fly and so what we started working with very
Early in my research career were optical fibers and this is the architecture of an optical fiber it's the same
Type of thing that is used to bring
cable into your house and transmit information and data over you know in high-speed and it's comprised of
really two critical elements here something called a core and
something that surrounds that that is a cladding and
Most of these fibers are made out of just two slightly different
versions of glass one the core typically is a very pure glass
that's it's almost like quartz a very pure glass made of
Silica and then that cladding is made of a of a doped
Silica with a little bit of germanium in it that actually causes a very
Important feature of the optical fiber that I'll show you on the next slide
This other stuff
here the pink and the green region here that's just the protective coating the allows you to
Handle these things because these fibers this the central core is about the diameter of a human hair
Could even be smaller than that and even though you can wrap these things around your finger if they get any
Imperfection they'll just break and so they they protect these things with a little bit of plastic
coating and so what I want to show you here is really the way that this works and and
Here you can see kind of a cross-section here
This is the core and this is the cladding and the only thing you really need to know about this optical fiber is
that at that
Interface between the core and the cladding that just that very microscopic layer there
You get something called total internal reflection
Meaning that that cladding acts as a mirror and so when you shine light into the fiber it bounces around and it can bounce around
You can have a spool of optical fiber that's a hundred miles long and the signal will go all the way through that
Because you lose very little light in an optical fiber and so you know some some
fibers need some wavelengths need to have
amplifiers in them to sort of you know boost the signal as they're going across the ocean but usually they can go for about
$100 typically without any kind of amplification
so
How do we make these things well this was a technology that
Was developed at Corning Glass back in the late?
1960s and what is done is to create what's called a preform and so these are cylinders of glass
they're typically
about the size of what you are actually seeing projected on the screen here so they're you know a few inches in diameter
there is a
cladding in there's a core in here and then that's surrounded, by another, glass that's that's a cladding and
What they do is they take what's called this big glass this big glass cylinder, that's called a preform and
put it into a
the top of
About a two to six storied drawing tower so this building
put it at the top and what you do is you begin to heat that fiber and
Glass begins to flow as it gets heated and it begins to drip
it melts and drips and it drips and
all the way down six stories onto this thing called a capstan that's just a
Rotating cylinder and what happens is that thing begins to spool that optical
Fiber is its melting and it cools all the way down those two to six story
time that it's dropping through and these things end up they can be drawn to a
Variety of diameters depending on how fast the cylinders
Rotating and how fast it's melting but the remarkable thing about this
Whole process is that if you start. Here with let's say a
two inch diameter
Core and a half inch diameter clad the
Ratio of the glass in that very thin fiber that's the diameter of a hair is
identical to the ratio of the glass in that initial preform
okay, it's a remarkable thing they both melt at the same rate they both get drawn at the same rate and you end up with
From a preform that you know probably has that much glass you can end up with
literally thousands of miles of this hair like optical fiber how do we get back to
eyes
well
Here is something called an optical imaging fiber and so this is a fiber that has been drawn it has a
core and a clad and
what they do is after that first draw they take them and they chop it up and they pack them and
then
Draw it again and then they chop that up and draw it. Again. Such that you end up with an array
optical fibers
that now
Look like this this is a large optical fiber array but here's an optical fiber
Array, that's pressed against a piece of stationery and what you can see
Here is exactly that kind of pixelation that I was telling you about before
With the eyes of an insect that is
Each of these optical fibers is carrying either a blue or a white image and
as you lower the resolution you
Now no longer see that pixelation it now is able to carry an image I've got
two things I'm gonna pass around the room
Here's an imaging optical fiber this has
60,000
individual optical fibers in it and this is the
end of a preform of
one of these optical imaging fibers
So here that's
That's the diameter that it started with and you can see as it melted it was drawn into that
thing right there
Okay, and what I'd like you to do?
is I'm gonna pass
my cart around but I
Don't know if this is gonna work but
As I pass my cart around
what you can do is you will
hold it up to this hold it up to the card right in contact with it and
You'll be able to see a magnified version because we're going from the small small end to the big end see magnified version of my
name or pictures on this card and if you hold it up you know to the light you can actually see the structures of
The the individual fibers in here so don't drop it
We started with the eyes and?
I'm going to show you how we can make a nose out of
these eyes this is taken from
National Geographic
packing the early
1980s there I haven't seen a better version of this if you think about 1980s this turns out to be a pretty expensive
experiment because they used LEDs and back in the 1980s LEDs were were
incredibly expensive but they had an LED on this dog and
you know they had this this is not a real pheasant this is a
Well it may have once been a real pheasant but it's just a it's been
Spiked with a little bit of odor and you can see this dog come in you know it
Probably can't see it
Except you know in this in this flash exposure but you can see you
Can you can see the dog comes in and the dog doesn't do this
the dog comes in and sort of goes in and out of the plume it's tracking right very complex behavior and
What is the dog doing during this time it's sampling the environment it's sort of comparing
one sniff to the next sniff to see if the odor is
Increasing, or decreasing so that it can begin to to figure out where where things are too kind of orient you to the mammalian
Olfactory system you know after our nostrils is this
Very convoluted what's called epithelium sort of skin cells for lack of a better term that are
populated with these olfactory
Receptor neurons so these are just nerve cells that are
sampling the odor and they're sending signals back to
Little pea-sized structure called the olfactory bulb that is actually like a little
preprocessor it takes all those signals from all those
receptors in the in the neurons and
it then sends a
processed version of that to the olfactory center in the cortical regions of the brain
and so here's the
Odorants that are coming in to the olfactory epithelium
and these receptors are positioned here and there's a very interesting feature here of
the mammalian system and that is that
You notice that there's red and green and blue receptors and they're all kind of spread out throughout
the region there they're pretty much identical
to one another we actually as as mammals we have
about a thousand of these receptor types for
mammalian systems
somewhere between
you know 2 and 10% depending on the
organism of the the genes are of the genes are actually
devoted to the olfactory system the thing that's important here is that
they converge and so all the red ones
converge and all the blue ones converge and all the purple ones converge and all the green ones
Converge in this cartoon and the reason that that's important is because
if you if you just had one receptor
Measuring these things you wouldn't get much of a signal
but when you begin to
to have a thousand receptors each of which is expressed
about tens of thousands hundreds of thousands in dogs millions of times then you get this signal to noise
amplification you get a
Square root of the number of receptors
improvement in the in the the signal to noise so if I had two receptors square root of two is one point four
two over one point four pretty bad signal if I have a
Million square root of million is a thousand a thousand to one ratio and signal to noise so you really get an improvement
making these receptors
converging on to the olfactory bulb and really amplifying the signal and
So here is some tracings that were done with the fruit fly this is a fairly simple odor?
Recognition system but here's the most important feature of the olfactory system and that is that you look at these
Six different odors here and what you notice is that
many of them respond to many different things so here this caproic acid and
Octa, known to very different
Compounds two different odors are being recognized by the same after here
but what's being processed is this pattern so it's this pattern of
response that actually is what gives the signal to the brain and so here's a
technical
Representation of this here's the odor it's presented to this array you get this response the response is
Recognized as a pattern and then the key for us is that when you first smell
Coffee, when you're two years old you say Bobby what's that and she says?
Oh, that's coffee and you remember that but here's a really interesting feature of the olfactory system
That is that those receptors that I showed you before
Are all replaced every six months every
six months yet
we've all had this experience you go into
Somebody's home for the first time and you say gee that smells like my grandmother's house
alright you have that olfactory memory and
so
something is
keeping the wiring
Constant and so this is a real challenge
for those of us who try to
mimic
these
kinds of systems in devices
because
unlike
most sensors that have to be calibrated
every time if you had to train one of these kinds of things if you to train your nose every six months to
Recognize every odor you encountered in your life you'd be in trouble why are we attracted to these
artificial nose as well
Because when we use patterns we can reduce the number of sensors because we get
Combinations that are unique when
You have ten sensors you can make lots of different
Combinations out of those ten sensors when they're which ones are on which ones are off and each one of those will give you some
Some information and so what we we try to do instead of making a sensor for glucose and a sensor for cholesterol
We take advantage of the principles of the olfactory system so that it recognizes everything it's anticipatory
we don't have to worry about trying to
make
Something that is specific for everything because that would take thousands or tens of thousands of sensors if we wanted to measure
Everything what we do is we train the system to recognize
everything that we're really interested in it transfers the burden from trying to make lots of different sensors to the to the
Computational processing so how do we do this in our first iteration
What we did is we?
took a bunch of these optical fibers not the one you saw here but ones that are like the
communication fibers the ones that have a single core and a single clad and we coated them with different fluorescent polymers and
then we took advantage of
this ability to now present these odors in a pulsatile fashion so
Similar to a sniff we just work in a puff of a vapor on these this sensor array that has
19 different polymers on them and
We're gonna sniff it and we're gonna watch the the temporal response so what I'd like to show you now is a movie
this is a
nineteen
fiber sensor array being exposed to benzene
So there you go that's
Played again a couple times
It looks almost lifelike
What does this look like so we digitized these data and here's the response you just slide
For some reason did not come out when I imported it into my new computer so there's a yellow and a black
Line for every one of the traces but you can see you know this sensor goes up fast
This sensor goes down and we're using these temporal responses and we?
Train a computer then we say
This is the response of these 19 sensors to benzene then, we?
expose it to a bunch of different things
And here's what we get this is the true identity of these 20 different
Compounds vapors that we exposed it to and this is what the computer tells us
It thinks these things are so
acetone very simple organic molecule
the computer gets it right 24 out of 24 times and these were presented in random order by the way they weren't just 24
Presentations of this and 24 presentations of that anything on the diagonal is correct
but anything off diagonal means it
Made a mistake so let's look at this here's a this this doesn't look right here this is number 10
We know number 10 is this I
guess cologne and
it mistakenly thought it was number 3
Well number 3 is a perfume
so
it it's making mistakes that are
Similar to what the kind of mistakes that we would make you know if you're?
presented with a
Cabernet and
you know maybe you can't tell the difference between Napa and Bordeaux the goal of this was actually to
build these things to sniff explosives for buried landmines
So here this is a very low concentration of a nitro aromatic compound like TNT
That's put into water you to sort of train dogs so number 19 is
correctly identified 20 out of 24 times but four times out of 24
Its mistaken is number 11. Which is water so it actually can smell water
Because machines can do that people can't we've kind of
Recapitulated the the mammalian system but I told you that there is a problem the problem is that
if we made this sensor array and we trained it it's like replacing your
Receptors every six months if you had to retrain your brain you'd have a problem
you wouldn't recognize anything that you previously had smelled how do we get around that well
We'd like to be able to do this we'd like to Train one sensor
Develop a computational
Recognition system and then have that transfer to any other sensor
we make after that
So that they can be used for a long time and so this is where we get to these optical imaging fibers
We discovered that we could
selectively etch
the cores of the fiber relative to the cloud material I told you that they were
Slightly different kinds of glass ones a slightly softer glass is able to be etched with
Something called hydrofluoric acid it's what they use to make
Frosted glass and so what we created here are these little
wells at the end of the fiber but here's their still a core here at the bottom of the well that is able to to
Shine light into that well well we filled these, things with little
Plastic beads that had fluorescent dyes attached to them one of these beads is sized
perfectly
to be able to
Fit into a well and one bead and one bead only and it sort of snuggles in there and it's stuck in there
And so what we did is we?
Made a bunch of these little
Beads these are really tiny they're three microns in diameter that's smaller than a cell
Okay
smaller than a human cell in one gram of these so kind of a thumb
There's about 10 billion of these beads we mix them all together and then we displayed them randomly
into the
60,000 Wells on that little piece of glass that is coming around so there's
60,000 of these beads there's about 10
Different bead types so there's
6,000 beads of each type
that's the amplification we need
we just figure out where the beads are by
Exposing them to a vapor and the green beads respond this way the blue beads this way red beads this way and the computer can
recognize those unique responses and then map the array and every array is mapped differently but they it contains the same
Bead types in there here's the bead types you can see the chemistry there this is 40 beads so they're highly reproducible
But you know you can sort of see
when you pulse
This compound D MMP on here you can see the beads changing and then they return to baseline a few seconds later here are
very low concentrations
parts-per-billion of some compounds kind of in the range that dogs can smell explosives
any one of these signals is really noisy you can kind of see it right here but if you take a
Thousand of them and you sum them up this is what I was getting at before the noise
Kind of averages out and the signal builds up and you begin to see a very
robust strong signal and so you you have the ability now to
begin to smell things very sensitively and
because you have
10 billion beads in a gram you
can make billions of sensors out of these and so we did that and
These are with three different sensors over a period of months and you can see, we we were almost perfect
with our ability to train a
Computational classifier and then completely replace that with another artificial nose so I want you to see there's
seventeen thousand seven hundred
exposures of which only four hundred contained anything
most of them were just blanks just air
Because we wanted to see if the system picked up anything by mistake that
Wasn't really there and it never did you know these are the sensor responses to different coffees
different cheeses you can see with your own eyes that they're different responses right they're smelling things differently and we can train a
Computer to recognize these and use them so when we're talking about
mimicking
Biology
we decided to see why do dogs have these big long noses and
So we took a cat scan of a dog's nose this
Was done at Tufts vet school and you can see this is the cross-section this is the olfactory epithelium
Remember I told you it's highly convoluted
You can really see how much surface area there is in a dog's nose and this is another
Cross-section a little bit further back toward the the eyes there's
lots and lots of olfactory cells here that are really
Amplifying the signal laser prototype this dog's nose, we made all those convolutions made a plastic mold
We cut it in half after we're done with this experiment we actually stuck our sensors
Into different regions of the nose same sensors same same chemistry what you can see is
This is a single sensor put in different regions of the dog's nose
The same sensor in different parts of the dog nose actually see different things because the odors are actually
separating they're partitioning so complex odors are
Presenting different things to different places in the dog's nose even though they're the same sensor you know this is kind of a fun experiment
ROMs perfumes vodkas and in every case we got an improvement in our ability to
Classify these things by just putting the sensors in different parts of the dog's nose these are hard things it's alcohol and water essentially
we got an improvement in in performance diverse sensor types allow you to be
Anticipatory we have replicates that improve their sensitivity and then we have the ability to make these things
Reproducible that allows you to maintain trained
over a long period of time so we talked about mimicking biology let me spend a few minutes talking about measuring
Biology I know there's some non scientists in the audience this is what's called the central dogma
the DNA gets converted into RNA
Many, copies of RNA and then RNA gets translated into protein and these are the micro Wells on the end of this fiber
And we first came up with these H well
Technologies this was what was referred to as micro, well arrays back, when we did this in the late nineteen
1990s and I've gone back and sort of done calculations but this particular fiber has a
Thousand times as many wells as
That piece of plastic in terms of the volume that one of these
Wells can hold relative to the volume one of these can hold it's five billion times
smaller
I always tell people now if you have that many zeros in front over or after something pay attention to it you know I already
Showed you that we can functionalize these beads with polymers that give you
Measurements that replicate the olfactory system then we started catching
single strands of DNA to these beads to be able to measure
The presence or absence of a complementary sequence of DNA that, was present in a solution so you know DNA or RNA?
DNA is double
double-stranded it's a double helix you can unwind that and then you can measure whether that the
Complementary strand is present by
probing it with a
Complementary strand that's attached to your surface here or you can bind RNA and measure that and so when we began to do this
With these beads it turned out to be a pretty
Transformative thing and the reason it was transformative is that you have these little micro wells we have these little
Beads we just put a droplet of these beads on top of this micro well array and the beads go in the wells
we don't have to do any sort of complex
assembly it's just a
Self-assembly process and so we publish this paper you know this is exactly that fiber that I passed around it's
13,000 Wells it's a very small part of that so there's four of these areas that you could actually
interrogate and at the time that we publish this this was the smallest size of one of these
DNA arrays that could be made and so now we came up with a way of being able to measure essentially a
Thousand things in the same area that you previously could only measure
one and so this really transformed the whole field of genetic
analysis
we founded a company many of you
Who are in science recognize the name of this kind is called Lumina this is the first product it was
96 of those fibers that I passed around the room positioned in
perfectly to fit into those little
96-well plastic plates that I showed you a couple slides ago and then over time they started making them
Fetching them in silicon and you know now one of these slides can you know has
literally hundreds of billions of beads and can measure 20 million letter
differences in
DNA between two samples and at the time that we you know first came out with this technology
people were charging $1 per letter of DNA and today
It's less than a ten thousandth of a cent and so what is that enabled that's
enabled
Things that you're very familiar with so this is the technology that's behind 23andme I would call it
recreational genomics but they did get approval for a consumer colon test it's also the technology that's used to measure the
genetic diversity and populations they use these things all the time for breeding
Cattle for breeding corn there's all sorts of things that these things are used for and the companies
become incredibly successful with lots of people so the last thing I'm going to talk about is proteins they're the the
catalysts
Or enzymes that are
Catalysts that make all the reactions happen in our body but the problem has
Been that there's a technology
This has been around about 50 years called iliza it's the way that the clinical tests for proteins are measured it's called an immunoassay
And it's able to measure things in this concentration range so this is millimolar topeka
Molar and it's known that in the bloodstream there's
325 proteins that are in that concentration range
But after the human genome was sequenced
It was determined that of those?
20,000
243 genes that code for the proteins in our bodies about fifth of those about
4000 of those should be present in the blood it's just that we don't have a way to measure them so
Imagine what we could do if we could measure all those proteins and so we developed something called Samoa
So just representing all the proteins that we couldn't measure back you know 10 years ago and so we developed this
Technology this is what eliza
does it measures the intensity of a color
Proportional to the concentration of a protein and this is what we do we have come up with a way to
literally digitize the signals of individual molecules so these are signals that are coming from the binding of
Individual protein molecules and it's an
Absolute measurement you know here if I ask you what's the concentration
Here you'd have to have something to compare it to right you'd have to hold it up to two little cards and say
Oh, yeah I think it's somewhere between these two colors here
Is absolute there's four molecules right there
You don't have to calibrate and so we published this eight years ago so the first thing we attempted was to measure
Something called PSA there's a few men with gray hair in the room here
You know PSA this is prostate specific antigen it's been discredited for screening for prostate cancer because men have very
different baseline levels of this and it turned out that this single molecule
Approach the Samoa approach is able to detect
PSA at levels that are about three thousand times
lower in concentration than the
Standard Eliza that I showed you this was also have been commercialized by a company that's based in Lexington
the arrays actually DVDs they're made by Sony on the same line that they
Used to make DVDs how many of you have bought a DVD lately
So that's why Sony's making these things now I
Know this is art and science so my friend Felice Frankel took a beautiful image of these so here's these microwell arrays that are
literally embossed on the surface of these
DVDs they're three micron wells there's two hundred and sixteen thousand of them there here's why we wanted to measure
PSA because men who've had prostate surgery they have their prostate removed and this molecule this protein that gets produced by the prostate gland
that disappears
but if there was
residual tumor that was left in when they the surgeon took the tumor out or if there was
metastasis prior to the surgery then that cancer begins to grow back and over time
It grows back above the range that now it can be measured
Because the tumor is larger there's more. PSA that's being produced by these
prostate
cancer cells and
every six months the patient goes in and gets a blood test and
most of the time they say
Oh, we can't detect it we can't detect it we? Can't detect and then they go come back and somebody says
oh
I've bad news for you you have a recurrence of your prostate cancer
well
we didn't think that was the best way to approach things first we took 20 men who were
Unmeasurable these were men who had their prostate removed
Through surgery and they were unmeasurable using the conventional test
Here's the limit of detection of the conventional test we could measure every one of them and here's our limit of detection
This is a log scale so we've got a long way to go but look at there's huge variation
Here, I'm not saying that this person's gonna recur or this person is not going to recur
It's just isn't it better to know the number and to be able to say
It's increasing over time we probably think you've got residual cancer and therefore we're gonna treat you before it gets
Super bad well this was a retrospective study and what this shows is that we could predict with a single blood test
Between three and six months after surgery with a hundred percent
Confidence that these men would not have recurrence of prostate cancer so these is a retrospective study they'd
Collected samples over a long period of time just went out to five years we could tell somebody a man
Between three and six months after their surgery you don't have to worry about it
but if you have levels below this you better worry because only thirty five percent of those men were
Cancer-free after five years if their level between three and six months, was above that
Concentration level so we decided to do something for women
because we think we have the ability to measure a tumor that is one millimeter in diameter
five millimeters this is the best you can do with imaging
this is mammography the best mammography picks up tumor this big this is what
We?
Think we can do by measuring blood borne biomarkers and the difference in volume is a hundred and twenty five times
so the idea is if you can detect these things early you have the ability to
Maybe watch and wait and see if something develops over time
Or if it just stays the same you don't have to treat so we're not advocating
over treatment and over diagnosis we just like to know and so this these are the statistics
pretty pretty bleak a quarter of a million new cases of invasive breast cancer every year and
smaller number of non invasive breast cancers one eight women will be diagnosed with breast cancer and forty thousand deaths it is
Absolutely true for breast cancer as well as for other cancers that the earlier you detect
the better the outcome
Pretty much 100% survival if you detect it early so
We ran some samples these are some preliminary results with
66 newly diagnosed women with breast cancer
Prior to their therapy we took a blood sample consented them and then we trained a system to recognize
eight proteins that we had identified
We thought might be useful for early detection of breast cancer this is all healthy patients
Versus breast cancer patients so all breast cancer all stages and we get?
accuracy of 96% mammography by the way is 82%
okay, a lot of false positives
some false negatives
When we only look at. Early stage breast cancer
The accuracy goes up a little bit so we think we have a blood test
That can do early detection of blood cancer by measuring proteins that have never been measured before so these are just eight
We're now up to 30 you know we've got about 400 samples now that we're gonna start running through and begin to to consent
whirlwind tour of the
optical system of insects
Mammalian noses measuring genes and measuring proteins and of course you know I could not have done this
Myself requires a large number of people and this is just current group members and maybe a few former ones that I think were particularly
Important for putting in here as either collaborators or former students who had contributed to some of the things that I talked about today
so happy to answer any questions
delighted to be here and thanks